Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速告知大家一件现在正在发生的激动人心的事。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你源源不断带来收入的方式，而不是不断用时间去换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续性收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up today, what is ADHD and how does it present in adults? We are talking with
这些原则都对你适用。此外，还有由丽莎本人亲自送出的丰厚奖品可供赢得。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战赛，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一一小时指导的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好啦，让我们继续今天的节目。接下来，什么是多动症（ADHD），它在成年人身上是如何表现的？我们将与
Maddy, who has recently been diagnosed with ADHD, and we're discussing her experiences of growing up, seeing that play out for herself, and also when she had her realisation moments and what taking medication has been like, how that has changed her and how she is super pleased now that she knows what she knows and how that has become her superpower. This is so relevant for us, whether we are neurodivergent ourselves, whether we are living or working or supporting clients who are neurodivergent. I hope you'll find this so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, you will have to have been living in a cave to not have seen the recent surge in press attention and social media attention for issues around neurodiversity.
玛蒂（Maddy）进行对话，她最近被诊断出患有多动症。我们讨论了她成长过程中的经历、她自己如何意识到这一点、她经历顿悟时刻的感受，以及服用药物是怎样的体验、药物如何改变了她，以及她现在如何为自己能够知晓这一切而感到无比高兴，并且如何将这转化为了她的超能力。这对我们非常相关，无论我们自己是神经多样性人群，还是与神经多样性人群共同生活、工作或为他们提供支持。我希望你会发现这非常有用。嗨，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》（Aspiring Psychologist）播客。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。现在，你得一直生活在山洞里，才不会注意到最近媒体和社交媒体对神经多样性相关议题的激增关注。
And I am here for it. I think it's incredibly empowering and really, really useful and helps people to understand things about themselves both now and maybe in the past and how to plan and better prepare for things in future too. Today's episode we are looking at ADHD and it is a brilliant listen and one that I hope you will find is time well spent. I will catch you on the other side. I just want to welcome along Maddy to the podcast today. Hi Maddy. Hey Marianne, thanks for having me. Thank you for saying yes. So we are in several business networks together and we've kind of got to know each other that way and what really stood out was obviously your amazing content which we'll come on to talk about later but you have recently had an ADHD diagnosis haven't you? Can I ask you what does ADHD mean to you and for you? So it all kind of came about in a really weird way so I knew nothing about ADHD probably
我完全支持这一点。我认为这具有令人难以置信的赋能作用，真的非常非常有用，它有助于人们了解自己现在乃至过去的某些情况，以及如何为未来的事情做出更好的规划和准备。今天的节目我们聚焦于多动症（ADHD），这是一期精彩绝伦的节目，我希望你会觉得这段时间花得很值得。我们节目另一端见。我只想欢迎玛蒂来到今天的播客。嗨，玛蒂。嗨，玛丽安，谢谢你邀请我。谢谢你答应。我们一起加入了几个商业网络，我们就是通过这种方式认识彼此的。真正突出的显然是你那些精彩的内容——我们稍后会讨论这个，但你最近被诊断出患有多动症（ADHD），对吧？我可以问你，ADHD对你意味着什么，对你有什么意义吗？所以这一切都以一种非常奇怪的方式发生了，大概在
three four years ago. All I thought was it was that, you know, that naughty little boy thing that people have when they're in primary school. And my son's teacher called me in and said, we think Ben's got ADHD. And I was like, but he's not naughty. And they said, you don't have to be naughty. So I went away and I did loads of research on it and fell into the TikTok rabbit hole. I mean, I spend a lot of time on TikTok anyway. But it was it was a very interesting rabbit hole. And I came back out the other side going, Oh, this is me. This is all of this is me. I've got all of all of these symptoms. And kind of forgot about Ben, bless him. Horrible mum. And I focused on getting my diagnosis. So I decided after going to the NHS that it was going to be a very, very, very long process.
三四年前，我对ADHD一无所知。我所知道的全都是那种，你知道的，人们在小学里那种淘气的小男孩才会有的东西。然后我儿子的老师把我叫去，说：“我们觉得本（Ben）得了ADHD。”我说：“但他不淘气啊。”他们说：“你不需要表现得淘气。”于是我回去做了大量的研究，掉进了 TikTok（抖音海外版）的兔子洞里。我的意思是，我本来就在 TikTok 上花了很多时间。但这真是一个非常有趣的兔子洞。我从另一头爬出来时说：“哦，这就是我。所有这些全都是我。我身上有所有这些症状。”然后，可怜的本，我就把他给忘了。我真是个糟糕的妈妈。我专注于去确诊。因此，在去过英国国民 NHS 之后，我认定这将是一个非常、非常、非常漫长的过程。
So I got a private diagnosis initially. Then there was that Panorama documentary about the diagnoses that private people give out. And I just doubted myself so much. I thought, no, maybe it's maybe they've misdiagnosed me. Maybe I don't have it at all. So I went back to the NHS and I thought I will get back on the waiting list and I got referred referred through Psychiatry UK right to choose which sped up the process a lot so we're talking you know three year waiting list down to like nine months and I got my ADHD diagnosis and the lady who was my psychiatrist said I've never seen anybody present their symptoms more ADHD-ly than you and I was like I'll take that as a compliment and she said but also I think you're autistic and I was like no I'm not autistic no no no no no I'm not having any of that not a chance went away and did a bit of research on autism as well i was like maybe possibly i don't know not not really and then i got my adhd
所以我最初做了一个私立诊断。然后就出现了关于私立机构给出的诊断的 Panorama 纪录片。我当时对自己产生了深深的怀疑。我想，不，也许是……也许他们误诊了我。也许我根本就没有。所以我又回到了 NHS，我想我得重新排队等候，然后我通过 Psychiatry UK 的“选择权”（Right to Choose）被转诊了，这大大加快了流程。所以我们说的是，你知道的，三年的等待名单缩短到了大约九个月。我拿到了 ADHD 的诊断结果，身为我精神科医生的女士对我说：“我从来没见过任何人表现出的症状比你更像 ADHD 了。”我说：“我把这当成是赞美吧。”她说：“但同时，我认为你也是自闭症患者。”我当时就想：“不，我不是自闭症患者。不，不，不，不，我才不要那些标签，绝对不可能。”我离开后也对自闭症做了一点研究，心想：也许、可能吧，我不知道，好像不太像。然后我拿到了我的 ADHD
medication and i started taking that and then all of a sudden oh hello autism there you are so it completely unmasked me um i did i did a a basically a cpPD accreditation as a neurodiversity in the workplace specialist. And I learned all about all the other neurodivergent conditions. And I've got all of them apart from Tourette's. There's there's a lot there to unpack. But for me, having my ADHD diagnosis was the thing that literally changed my life. I went from feeling like a completely broken, unfunctional horse to realizing my superpower. And now I just embrace my neurodiversity. And I'm just a crazy wild zebra that does things the way that she does them. And when you have that moment of realization,
药物，开始服用，突然之间——哦，你好，自闭症，原来你在这儿。所以它彻底让我“解除了伪装”。我基本上完成了一个作为职场神经多样性专家的 cPPD 认证。我了解了所有其他神经多样性的情况。除了妥瑞症（Tourette's）之外，我全都有了。这里有很多东西需要去理清和消化。但对我来说，拥有 ADHD 诊断结果是真正改变我生活的事情。我从一个感觉自己彻底破碎、无法正常运转的废人，变成了意识到自己的超能力。现在我只是拥抱我的神经多样性。我只是一只疯狂狂野的斑马，按照她自己的方式做事。当你有了那个顿悟的时刻——
that actually, you're not broken, you know, it's made such a difference in my story because you know I had I had my money story I was in forty thousand pounds worth of debt um I struggled throughout my whole life with money spending addiction um all sorts of problems and all of a sudden I was like oh that makes so much sense that like. I didn't just spend because I was really bad with money. I spent because my brain was craving the dopamine. So it was very interesting. And I also realized after my diagnosis that I'd spent six years in business trying to follow the gurus and the people who were all really successful. And I realized that the reason why I wasn't successful is because my brain doesn't work that way. And when I started doing things my way, I started to become successful. Weird. And
实际上，你并没有破碎。你知道的，这在我的故事中产生了如此巨大的影响，因为你知道的，我曾有过我的金钱故事，我背负了四万英镑的债务。我一生都在与金钱、消费成瘾以及各种各样的问题作斗争。突然之间，我觉得：“哦，这就说得通了。”我不仅是因为不善理财才花钱。我花钱是因为我的大脑在渴望多巴胺。所以这非常有趣。我在确诊后还意识到，我花了六年时间在商界试图模仿那些大师和所有真正成功的人。我意识到我之所以没有成功，是因为我的大脑不那样运转。而当我开始用我自己的方式做事时，我开始走向成功。真奇怪。然后
everything changed for me. So it's been absolutely life changing getting a diagnosis. Yeah, and I'm really pleased that it's given you such, I don't know, like, is it keyholder benefits or keyholder understanding? Or it's just been transformational, but's given you such I don't know like is it keyholder benefits or keyholder understanding or it's just been transformational but also given you permission to really lean into who you are and to see your special gifts and talents is exactly that absolutely um knowledge is power um and for anybody who is out there thinking or suspecting that they might have ADHD act like like you have it. If you think you've got it, the likelihood is that you probably do. And I started to embrace it from day one that I found all that information and thought, that's me. And that was the thing that changed. I didn't
一切都为我改变了。所以获得诊断绝对是改变人生的。是的，我真的很高兴它给了你这么大，我不知道，就像是拥有了金钥匙的好处，还是拥有了金钥匙般的理解？或者这简直具有变革意义，但也赋予了你真正倾听自我、展现真我的许可，去看到你独特的才能与天赋。完全就是这样，千真万千。知识就是力量。对于任何在外头思考或怀疑自己可能患有 ADHD 的人来说，那就表现得好像你真的有一样。如果你觉得自己有，那大概率你可能确实有。我从发现所有这些信息并心想“这就是我”的那天起，就开始拥抱它了。这就是改变现状的地方。我没有
wait for the diagnosis to start owning it. I just owned it from day one. And I think if you wait and you kind of hang around in that limbo area, you don't have the knowledge is power situation. So I just went from not knowing I had it to knowing I had it. Because when you know, you know, and then that just gave me all of the knowledge that I could put together. And also it helped me to learn from my mistakes and all of the things that I've messed up on over the years. it made me to it made me feel like I was actually more successful than I was I'm so pleased you've had that experience of you know coming home I guess really um but just before we hit record I said oh I think I probably do you know fit within the criteria of ADHD and you're like yeah I think
等着确诊才开始去接受它。我从第一天起就接受了它。我认为如果你只是等待，然后在那个处于灰色地带的边缘徘徊，你就不会拥有“知识就是力量”这种状况。所以我从不知道自己有，直接过渡到知道自己有。因为当你懂了就是懂了，然后这给了我所有可以拼凑在一起的知识。这也帮助我从错误中吸取教训，以及过去这些年我搞砸的所有事情中吸取教训。它让我觉得自己实际上比以前更成功了。我太高兴你有这样的体验了，就是那种“回到家”的感觉，真的是这样。但在我们按下录音键之前，我说：“哦，我觉得我可能确实符合 ADHD 的标准。”而你说：“对，我也觉得你可能符合。”是什么让你这么说的？你那灵敏的直觉是什么？
I think you probably do too what made you say that what was your spidey sense so one of the things that like especially if you do neurodiversity in the workplace like we don't diagnose people so but I think it it does take one to know one we gravitate towards people who have similar traits, similar values, similar brain function. And I just you can get a feel from somebody with how fast they talk, like what they talk about, like the sharing situation. We're kind of oversharers a little bit, like not in a bad way, because I always think that the more people know know about me the more they'll like get to know like and trust me and the more people will want to work with me so I'm like an open book my husband hates it he's like I can't believe you just said that somewhere publicly but but for me it's just like what you see is what you get and I think you'll quite like that as well which I really like um so for me it's it's very much
所以其中一件事是，特别是如果你从事职场神经多样性方面的工作，我们并不诊断别人，但我觉得“同类才能识别同类”。我们会不自觉地被那些拥有相似特质、相似价值观、相似大脑功能的人吸引。你可以从一个人的说话速度、他们谈论的话题、以及分享的情况中感受到一种氛围。我们有点像那种过度分享的人，也不是说不好，因为我总是认为，人们对我的了解越多，他们就会越喜欢我、了解我并信任我，也会有更多人愿意跟我合作。所以我就像一本翻开的书。我丈夫恨死这样了，他说：“真不敢相信你刚才在公共场合说出了那种话。”但对我说，这就是“所见即所得”。我想你也会挺喜欢这一点的，我确实挺喜欢的。所以对 F 来说，这非常
like I will never say to somebody you've got ADHD but I think you know when you meet somebody who suspects they've got ADHD you can kind of say well if you suspect it you know your own brain right so you're probably right yeah and I think in terms of being able to quickly attune and warm and feel comfortable with people it's an excellent skill in psychology as well and in business coaching that you do um and it means that you you know and i think we're being podcasters both of us are podcasters you have to be your genuine self otherwise it comes across in a really staged manner and that just doesn't it doesn't sit well no no I just I talk on podcasts like I would talk to somebody if I was sat in a room with them like nobody needs that forced that forced staged thing
像——我永远不会对某人说“你得了 ADHD”，但我想你知道的，当你遇到一个怀疑自己有 ADHD 的人时，你基本上可以说：“嗯，如果你怀疑的话，你了解你自己的大脑，对吧？所以你大概是对的。”是的，而且在能够迅速调频、变暖、并让人感到舒适方面，这也是心理学领域的一项极佳技能，你做商业教练时也是如此。这意味着你懂——而且我认为我们作为播客主，我们两个都是播客主，你必须展现最真实的自我，否则就会显得非常刻意和做作，而那种表现真的感觉不对劲。没错，不会的。我上播客说话的方式，就跟我坐在房间里和某人聊天时一模一样。没有人需要那种强装出来的、刻意做作的东西。
um I think it does also come from years of being an influencer as well. I just, I rock up on TikTok. I talk there every day. I share my innermost thoughts and feelings, but that's what people like. And that's the thing that helps me to get business. Yeah, definitely. And I think I'm thinking back to when I was working in CAMHS, which for anyone who's not familiar with that term, it stands for Children's and Adolescent Mental Health Services.
嗯，我觉得这大概也源于多年来作为网红的经历。我直接出现在 TikTok 上。我每天都在那里聊天。我分享我内心深处的想法和感受，但这正是人们喜欢的。这也是帮我开展业务的原因。是的，绝对的。我想回想一下我以前在 CAMHS 工作的时候，对于任何不熟悉这个词的人来说，它代表儿童和青少年心理健康服务（Children's and Adolescent Mental Health Services）。
And we were having to kind of go into school and do observations. And quite often would be I'd be saying to the school that the child often didn't know I was coming. They didn't know they'd been referred. This was like the first stage of assessment. And they'd be saying, the teacher would be saying, well, there's no problem with them. You know, quite often if it was a girl, of course, there's no problem with them. They're fine. And I'm like, well, let's just take a moment to actually take a look at them together. Let's look at the behaviours that are required to sit still when sitting still is expected. You know,
我们得去学校做观察。很多时候，我会对学校说，孩子通常不知道我要来。他们甚至不知道自己被转诊了。这是评估的第一阶段。他们会说，老师会说：“他们没问题啊。”你知道，当然，如果是个女孩的话，她们当然没问题，她们很好。而我会说：“好吧，让我们花点时间一起来看看他们。让我们来看看当被要求坐得安静时，坐得安静所需要的行为是什么。”你知道的，
I'm saying, actually, because what I'm seeing here is, you know, pen fiddling and elastic band tranging and, you know, dropping things on the floor all the time. And actually, if you look there, they're sitting in quite a constrained way. So at the moment, I've got my legs wrapped around each other. And, you know, often in school settings settings it's the children that you're constantly having to say stop rocking on your chair that actually might well end up fitting quite nicely with an adhd diagnosis and they're like why do i have to keep telling you and it's like actually it's because these are the behaviors that we're seeing from a child or a young person or an adult when sitting still is expected and they want to be
我说：“实际上，因为我在这里看到的是，你知道的，转笔、拉弹橡皮筋，还有，你知道的，一直在地上掉东西。实际上，如果你仔细看，他们坐的姿势相当拘束。”所以此时此刻，我的双腿正盘在一起。而且，你知道的，通常在学校环境中，那些老师不得不经常对他们说“别在椅子上摇晃”的孩子，实际上可能非常符合 ADHD 的诊断。他们会问：“为什么我总得提醒你？”而实际上，这是因为当被要求保持安静时，我们在一个孩子、年轻人或成年人身上看到的正是这些行为。他们希望
deferent to that they want to show that they're being respectful they want to maybe be able to engage with the learning what are they having to do to themselves or with themselves or for themselves to allow that to happen and once you can kind of get people's heads around that so my husband doesn't think that I fidget and yet I'm in constant motion I feel even when we're sitting still watching tv constantly moving my arms and my legs like because I want to sit still but those are my compensatory behaviors yeah absolutely it's weird that you say about like twisting legs around and stuff like and that's just been a penny drop moment for me that as a child when I was stood still rather than having my feet like this I used to do that I used to do that um and that's really weird because everyone used to be like why are
顺从这一点，他们想表现出自己很尊重规则，他们可能希望能够投入到学习中去。为此，他们必须对自己做什么、对自己做什么、或为了自己做什么来让这一切发生呢？一旦你能让人们大致理解这一点——我丈夫不认为我有小动作，然而我却一直在动。即使当我们坐着看电视时，我也在不停地动我的手臂和腿，因为我想坐安静，但这些都是我的代偿行为。太对了，简直不可思议。你刚才说把腿缠绕在一起之类的事，对我来说真是一个“醍醐灌顶”的时刻。作为一个孩子，当我站着不动而不是像这样把脚放好时，我以前就会那样做。我以前就是那样做的。这真的很奇怪，因为过去每个人都问：“你为什么站成那样？”但我只是觉得我的双腿很不舒服，我觉得它们那样放感觉更好。所以你这么说真的很有趣。是的，那里也有一些感官上的重叠。所以可能并不是每个患有 ADHD 的人都喜欢奇怪的腿部姿势，但对我来说，你知道的，我也喜欢毯子。晚上睡觉时我的床上要盖很多毯子，夏天我觉睡得极差，因为我喜欢
you standing like that but I just I felt uncomfortable in my legs and I it felt better that they went that way so really interesting that you said that yeah there's some sensory overlap there as well so probably not not everyone with ADHD has weird leg positioning but for me it just you know I like blankets as well like I like lots of blankets on my bed at night and in summer I sleep terribly because I like the the layers and actually that's name that just keeps me stiller I am exactly the same so I can't sleep unless I've got something on top of me that sounds really wrong um but it has to be like I need the comfort of something being wrapped around me and that's never good when you're perimenopausal I just oh it's awful but yeah I think the there was a lot that happened
那种层层叠叠的感觉。实际上，正是这种重量让我能保持更安静。我完全一样。所以我必须在身上压点东西才能入睡，这听起来真的很不对劲，但必须得是那种被什么东西裹着的舒适感。当你处于围绝经期时，这可绝不是什么好事。我只是——哦，太糟糕了。但是的，我觉得
in my childhood that was completely and utterly overlooked um which would have been very much signs and signals I couldn't stay friends with people for very long um and when I did I hyper focused on them to the point where I smothered them and then they didn't want to be my friend anymore because they were like my one person um I lost my I had my best friend for eight years and I lost her because she basically just thought I was too much and my jealousy of her being friends with other people was just a bit a bit weird um I had problems in school where I would just talk to fill space and like people just didn't really like that um my my behavior wasn't amazing and in kind of primary school and like early years um I picked
我童年时发生了许多事情，被完全彻底地忽视了。这些其实是非常明显的迹象和信号。我无法和别人维持很长时间的朋友关系，当我交到朋友时，我会对他们过度专注（hyper focused），甚至到了窒息的地步，结果他们再也不想和我做朋友了，因为他们觉得我是他们的“唯一”。我曾有一个维持了八年的最好朋友，我失去了她，因为她基本上觉得我“太过了”。我对她和其他人交朋友的嫉妒心显得有点奇怪。我在学校里有问题，我会为了填补空白而喋喋不休，而人们其实并不太喜欢那样。我的行为在小学和低年级阶段并不是太好，我从其他孩子那里学到了
up things like bad habits like swearing and stuff from other kids but I couldn't couldn't keep it in so I would say things out loud which would get me in trouble and my mum took me to the doctors and I got diagnosed with an artificial colouring allergy which is very very typical for 80s girls who had ADHD. And I remember seeing you talking about that on socials recently and I think I even probably commented at the time that you know Joe Wicks has got himself in hot water recently for saying about kind of processed food but actually I think a lot of what he's saying really resonates for me so I grew up in a household where we ate lots of lentils and everything was homemade we were not vegetarian but the meat we had had to last a week like it was kind of a frugal household where everything was was homemade and that's you
坏习惯，比如骂脏话之类的。但我憋不住，所以我会大声说出来，这给我惹来了麻烦。我妈妈带我去看医生，我被诊断出对人工色素过敏，这对于患有 ADHD 的 80 年代女孩来说非常非常典型。我记得最近看到你在社交媒体上谈论这个，我想我当时可能还评论过，你知道的，乔·威克斯（Joe Wicks）最近因为谈论加工食品而陷入了舆论热议，但实际上我觉得他说的很多话真的很能引起我的共鸣。所以我是在一个吃很多扁豆、所有东西都是自制的家庭长大的。我们不是素食主义者，但我们吃的肉必须吃上一周——这是一个俭朴的家庭，所有东西都是自制的，这就是
know that's just what was the normal for me and when I was probably in my late primary school years I went to a McDonald's party and um the mother of the child said to me well what do you want Marianne what do you want to eat and I actually I was the kid that said I don't know what do they do because I'd never been to McDonald's before. And now as a parent of two young children, I couldn't, I can't really imagine that, you know, especially because it's even more prevalent now. But I'm, I'm 42, as we record this. So I was born in 81. And McDonald's was still pretty big business, even in the 80s and the early 90s. But what I noticed as I began to become more independent is that I was obviously buying things myself with my pocket money, or when I started to work, I'd be using my wages. And I actually thought that McDonald's made me what I called at the time
对我和我来说很正常的事。当我大概在上小学高年级的时候，我去参加了一个麦当劳派对。那个孩子的妈妈对我说：“你想吃什么，玛丽安？你想吃什么？”而我其实就是那个说“我不知道，他们卖什么？”的孩子，因为我以前从来没去过麦当劳。现在，作为两个幼童的父母，我真的无法想象，尤其是因为它现在更普遍了。但我们录音时我 42 岁了，所以我出生在 81 年。即使在 80 年代和 90 年代初期，麦当劳也已经是相当大的企业了。但我注意到，随着我开始变得更加独立，我显然是用自己的零花钱自己买东西，或者当我开始工作时，我会用我的工资。我实际上认为麦当劳让我变成了我当时所说的
hyper, whereas in actual fact, I think it was that I was so unused to artificial processed foods that my body sort of went into overdrive. Like it was like a stimulant to me. And so I think really, whilst Joe Wicks might not have said it exactly like that, I think that what he's saying is, is we've got to be able to give ourselves, not our children, but our children to the best chance of thriving by really trying to make sure that their that their nourishment is optimal. So that then whatever is unique for them, whatever their best potential is, they've then got the chance to reach their full potential. This isn't elitism. This isn't like only bright, only brainy kids are great. But, you know, if we're giving optimum nourishment to everybody in our family regardless of age that gives them the level platform to be able to reach their optimal performance yes and and i i agree i think where where joe wicks kind of messed up was was saying that people are being misdiagnosed with ADHD when really it's artificial colouring
“亢奋”（hyper），而实际上，我认为是因为我对人工加工食品太不习惯了，以至于我的身体有点进入了超负荷状态。就像它对我来说是一种兴奋剂一样。所以我觉得，虽然乔·威克斯可能没有表达得这么精确，但我认为他要表达的是：我们必须能够给我们自己——不是我们的孩子，而是让我们自己以及孩子们通过努力确保营养最优化，从而获得茁壮成长的最佳机会。这样无论他们身上有什么独特之处，无论他们最大的潜力是什么，他们才有机会发挥出全部潜力。这不是精英主义。这并不是说只有聪明、有才华的孩子才优秀。但是，如果我们无论年龄大小，都为家里的每个人提供最优化的营养，这就为他们能够达到最佳表现提供了一个公平的平台。是的，而且我同意，乔·威克斯搞砸的地方在于，他说人们被误诊为 ADHD，而实际上那是人工色素、糖分之类的东西。而我是反过来的情况：我被误诊为人工色素过敏，尽管我根本没有接触过任何那类食物——我们住在荒郊野岭，住在汉普郡村庄里一个农场隔壁，方圆几英里都没有麦当劳。我们从来没有吃过那种东西。我不吃糖，我们也不去镇上。一切都是自家烹饪的新鲜食物，我们住在村里，所以都是农场商店里的食物，全都是未加工的。所以当我得到那个诊断时，我妈妈说：“但她根本没有吃过那些东西啊。”而他们却说：“嗯，这就是原因，所以什么都别吃。”
sugar whatever and having that from kind of the other way around where I was misdiagnosed with an artificial colouring allergy even though I had had no exposure to any of those kind of foods like my pet we we lived in the middle of nowhere we lived in like next door to a farm in a in a village in the middle of Hampshire there was not a McDonald's for miles um we never had anything like that we like I didn't have sweets we didn't go into town it was like everything was home cooked and fresh and we lived in a village so it was all like farm shop food and none of it was processed so when when I got that diagnosis my mum was like but she doesn't have any of those things and they were like well that's what it is so don't have any of
这一切导致我作为一个青少年时出现了饮食问题，因为我突然之间接触到了巧克力、糖果以及我以前从未吃过的东西。我会攒下午饭钱，放学后去买糖果或巧克力，因为它能给我带来多巴胺，带给我嗨的感觉。所以小时候的那个误诊，对我的青少年时期的饮食方式产生了如此深远的连锁反应，甚至延续到了我的成年期。你知道的，我是一个超级糖瘾患者，你知道的，我真的希望我不是这样。而且这是导致我超重的原因之一，我觉得这是一件很难去思考的事情。所以当我听到那个时，我想
those um and that led to me having eating problems as a teenager because I was exposed then all of a sudden to chocolate and sweets and things that I'd never had before and I would save up my lunch money and I would go and spend it on sweets or chocolate after school because it gave me that dopamine and it gave me that high. So having that misdiagnosis as a child had such a knock-on effect on the way that I ate as a teen, but then also into my adult years. You know, I am such a sugar addict, you know I really wish I wasn't um and it's you know that's that's one of the things which has contributed to me being overweight and and I think that's that's a hard hard thing to think about um so when I when I heard that I thought
你知道吗，国民英雄乔——我们在大流行期间都很喜欢他——但在谈论一个他并不是真正理解的事情时，他确实犯了错误。是的，百分之百。我确实同意这样的观点：你知道的，加工食品对我们的孩子并不好，它们会导致过度活跃。但我觉得是“误诊”这件事触动了我的神经。谢谢你对此做出回应。你知道，每个人在这个问题上都有发言权是很重要的。那么你儿子呢？因为显然我们的许多听众可能会关注甚至从事儿童和青少年服务工作，这在他身上是如何表现的？他的老师和周围的人都观察到了什么？
you know what Joe heart of the nation you know we we loved him during the pandemic but he has made a mistake in talking about something that he doesn't really understand yes 100% I do agree with the fact that you know processed foods are not great for our kids and they can cause hyperactivity but I think it was the misdiagnosis thing that was the thing that kind of hit the nerve for me. Thank you for talking back to that it's you know it's important that everybody has a voice on this so how about your son then because obviously a lot of our listeners will be looking at perhaps they might even be working in children's and young people's services how was this showing up for him what was being observed by his teachers and those around him?
所以这是典型的过度活跃——在椅子上摇晃，但在本该上数学课的时候他却在倒立。就像完全无法静坐一样。现在他就像劲量电池（Duracell bunny）一样，真的完全停不下来。任何认识我的人可能都不会觉得这很意外，因为我跟他一模一样。但他真的是被体内的马达疯狂驱动着，这种表现有多强烈简直难以置信。他到现在还没有正式确诊，因为当时他的老师告诉我这件事时他才六岁，而他们不喜欢在七岁之前做诊断。所以他们已经落实了所有的步骤和流程，让他在学校的生活变得好得多。
So it was the the classic hyperactivity swinging on the chair but the fact that he was doing handstands when he should have been doing maths um like just not being able to sit still at all now he has he's like the Duracell bunny he literally just doesn't stop at all which for anybody who knows me is probably not that surprising because I'm exactly the same um but he is so so driven by a motor it is unreal how how much it shows up um he still hasn't had a formal diagnosis because it's at the time when his teacher told me about it he was six and they don't like doing it before seven so they've put put all of the steps and the processes in place to make his life at school so much better.
比如其他人不允许的时候他可以涂鸦。他想去散步时可以去。他们给他安排了类似的小休息时间，这样他就可以自己去坐一会儿。这些对他真的非常、非常有用。他们还把他安排进了“海米什和米洛”（Hamish and Milo）项目，该项目全部围绕焦虑展开。他们对他真的太棒了，非常非常优秀。不过我确实需要抓紧时间把他的诊断正式做完，因为我认为了解中学将是完全不同的情况。他现在九岁了。所以我觉得我们必须趁早而不是推迟。另一方面，我的女儿，她在很小的时候也表现出了 ADHD 的迹象，但更多的是自闭症。
Like he's allowed to doodle when other people aren't. He can go for walks when he wants to. They give him like little break times so he can go and sit on his own. And they are really, really good for him. They also put him into the Hamish and Milo programme, which is all about anxiety. And they they are brilliant with him. Really, really good. I do need to get a wriggle on and actually get his diagnosis properly done, though, because secondary school, I think, will be a completely different kettle of fish. And he's now nine. So I think we do have to do it sooner rather than later. My daughter, on the other hand, she is also really early on showing ADHD signs, but more autistic.
她数学非常好。拼写非常好。她的艺术作品水平大概能赶上十岁或十一岁的孩子，而她才五岁。我只想说——但她 18 个月大的时候就能搭积木了，不是那种简单的积木，是真正的乐高。也许给那么小的孩子玩这个不是最好的选择，但她完全能驾驭。她知道这不能塞进鼻孔，知道不能吃掉，知道必须用它来拼搭。她在 18 个月大时搭出的东西简直疯狂。不过我觉得，第二个孩子情况就是不一样，对吧？家里已经有了大孩子的玩具，小的孩子们才不想要这些无聊的婴儿玩具。
She is so good at maths. She's really good at spelling. She is like her artwork is probably as good as like a 10 or 11 year olds and she's five um I'm just like but she was building lego blocks like proper not even jukelo but lego she was building at 18 months um maybe not the best thing to give a child that young but she was just all over it she was just you know she knew it didn't go up her nose she knew she didn't eat it she knew she had to build with it and it was crazy the sort of thing she was building at 18 months old. I think second time around, though, it's just different, isn't it? You've got the older toys in the house already and the children, the young children don't want these boring baby toys.
他们想要那些令人兴奋的、无所不能的、全能的大龄儿童玩具。所以，是的，我觉得我们对老小确实更早地引入了乐高。是的。谢谢你向我们阐述你两个孩子的确切情况。作为一位妈妈——我有一个 10 岁的儿子，他将在 8 月满 11 岁，所以他目前读六年级——如果可以的话，最好尽量在你的儿子参加 SAT 考试之前把这件事搞定，那将是在他六年级的夏季学期，仅仅是因为——
They want those exciting, you know, all singing, all dancing, grown up kid toys. So, yeah, I think we definitely introduced Lego a lot sooner with my youngest. Yeah. So thank you for kind of illuminating us about the processes for both of your children. I would say as a mummy, so I've got a 10 year old, he's going to be 11 in August. So he's, he's in year six currently, it would be ideal if you can to try and get it sorted out before your son's SATs, which will be, you know, the summer term of his year six, just because um and obviously speaking as a qualified psychologist as well we really want to be getting him used to whatever's going on for him so that
而且显然作为一名合格的心理学家，我们真的很想让他习惯他身上发生的事情，这样你们在小学和中学之间就能有一个非常扎实的过渡计划。这也可能会影响你为他选择中学，你可能想找一个有资源教室的地方，或者只是一个能帮他做到最好的地方，因为如果你正处于几个不同招生片区的边缘，最重要的是确保为你们所有人做出最好的选择。这完全说得通。而且我觉得甚至细致到校服这样的事情——我担心的是，他的小学穿的是 Airtex T恤和慢跑裤。而他将不得不穿衬衫和领带，从感官的角度来看，这对他来说会非常困难。我认为这是一个很大的担忧。而且他现在的学校对于校服这类事情非常、非常宽松，比如他的校服毛衣扎人，他就穿
you've got a really solid transition plan between primary and secondary and it also might also influence your choice of secondary for him as well you might want to pick somewhere that's got resource spaces or just a you know something that's going to help him to do his very best because if you're kind of on the cusp of a couple of different catchment areas it's just about making sure that you're making the best choice for all of you really. It does make total sense and I think even down to things like school uniform like I worry about the fact that like his primary school, they wear Airtex T-shirts and joggers. And he's going to have to go to wearing shirt and tie and things which are going to be from a sensory perspective, really difficult for him. I think that's a big worry. And his school at the moment are really, really kind of lax about things like his school jump is itchy he doesn't wear
校服毛衣而是穿连帽衫，但学校觉得没关系。然而中学可不会觉得没关系。这就是过渡期，我心想：“是的，我想去中学，我想和我的朋友们一起去，一切都很好。”而我却在想：“我不想让你去，我太害怕了……”只是——做父母有时真的很艰难。但同时，也非常难。当你自己患有 ADHD 并且还有神经多样性的孩子时，做父母真的太难了。因为我认为，老实说，如果我早知道我现在对我的神经多样性状况的了解，以及除了妥瑞症之外我每种都有的事实，我想，
his school jumper he wears a hoodie but they're fine with that but secondary school they're not going to be fine with that and it's that transition where I think he's like yeah I want to go to secondary school I want to go with my friends and it's all fine and I'm like I don't want you to go I'm too scared like just uh it's it's it's hard being a parent sometimes but also it's really hard it's hard being a parent with ADHD when also, it's really hard. It's hard being a parent with ADHD when you've got neurodivergent kids. Because I think, being completely honest, if I'd have known what I knew now about my neurodivergent conditions, and the fact that I've got every single one of them, barterettes, I think, you know, parenting might not have been
如果我早点被诊断出来，做父母可能就不会在我的考虑范围之内了。所以我认为，从某些方面来说，早点确诊很棒，但同时我也不想改变我有孩子的事实。虽然他们有时真的很令人头疼，我也确实在育儿方面苦苦挣扎。我全心全意地爱我的孩子们，但养育孩子以及做育儿的事情——组织安排、接送放学，所有这些类似的事情——对我来说是一个巨大的挣扎。谢谢你如此诚实、如此赤裸地分享。
something on the cards for me if I'd have been diagnosed earlier. So I think you know parenting might not have been something on the cards for me if I'd have been diagnosed earlier so I think from certain aspects I think being diagnosed earlier is is great but also I wouldn't want to change the fact that I've got kids they might be really difficult at times and I do struggle with parenting I love my kids with all of my heart but parenting and doing parenting things organizing picking up from school all of my heart, but parenting and doing parenting things, organising, picking up from school, all of those kind of things, struggle for me massively. Thank you for being so honest and so raw.
你知道，我认为对于收听这期节目的听众来说，这也非常、非常具有解放意义。你知道，养育孩子真的很棘手，而且——我觉得我最头疼的事情是，我真的很想立刻把这件事做完。我真的很想马上完成这个。我真的很想现在就把这个做完。我真的不想停下手头的事去——你知道的——做你想要我做的事。这就是我所苦难的。所以，对我来说，抽出时间陪孩子很重要，但我希望在“我有时间陪孩子”的时候陪他们。而育儿并不总是按这个规律来的，所以你知道的——我希望我的
You know, I think that's really, really liberating for people who are tuning in to listen to this as well. You know, parenting is really tricky and it's, you know, I think the thing I find trickiest is I really want to do this right now um I really really want to finish this I really really want to finish this now I don't really want to stop what I'm doing to come and you know do whatever it is that you want to do that's what I struggle with so I like it's important for me to have time for my children but I want to have time for my children when I will have time for my children and parenting doesn't always work like that so you know it's I want to have my my
孩子们能体验到妈妈享受和他们在一起、陪伴他们的时光。但同时，因为我现在全职在家工作——今天我们录音的时候正好是我创业三周年纪念日——所以现在我总是待在家里。因为我在家工作，所以当他们在这里时，有时候妈妈还在工作，但他们只看到我一直在工作，这就是我的故事。是的，当我在 NHS 工作时，当妈妈一周有三天不在家，他们就接受了我是在上班。但当我在家时，他们把我视为一直都在家。这就是把它们融合在一起，对吧？所以很棘手，这不是一场轻松的——这不是一场容易的战役。不，这总是一种艰难的平衡。你知道，我的孩子们非常——他们不喜欢去课后托管班之类的。
children to have the experience of mummy enjoying spending time with them and being with them but also because I work from home solely now today as we record is my three-year self-employment anniversary um so I'm now always in um because I do work from home and so when they're here sometimes mummy is still working but they just see it as me always working um and that's my story yeah when I was when I was in the NHS when mummy was working for three of those days she was out of the house and so they would just accepted that I was I was at work but when I'm here they see me as being here and it's it's it's blending that isn't it so it's tricky it's not an easy it's not an easy battle no it's it's always a hard balance and you know my my kids are very like they don't like going to after school club for example so
所以，我基本上和他们做了个交易。我说：“好吧，如果你们不想去课后托管班，那我就去学校接你们。但当我回到家后，我必须继续工作，因为我需要完成一整天的工作。”他们十之八九都非常尊重这一点。但我女儿是个小恶魔，所以我确保这绝对不是在录播客的时候，也绝对不是在我被中途打断会有影响的事情。我总是必须提前警告那些我在放学接送回来后有通话的人：“真的很抱歉，我的女儿随时可能会进来要饼干，因为她就是离不开。”
I kind of basically made a deal with them I was like right if you guys don't like going to after school club for example so I kind of basically made a deal with them I was like right if you guys don't want to go to after school club then I'll come and pick you up from school but when I come home I have to still carry on working because I need to do a full day's work and they are nine times out of ten very respectful of that but my daughter is a nightmare so I make sure that it's never a podcast recording it's never something that matters if I get interrupted and I always have to warn the people I've got calls with after I get back from the school run really sorry but my daughter probably will come in at this at some point and ask for biscuits because she just she can't stay away
是的，我懂你。而且，我倾向于做的工作，我们的设置也是一样的。所以我们的育儿成本支出为零，我知道这是一个很好的位置，因为我就在这里。所以这一切都是我一个人搞定。但放学后，妈妈会给你拿点心，然后欢迎你坐在我身边的沙发上，看我工作、做我需要做的事情。你知道的，我那些时候不看诊。所以我在那些时间不看诊，
yeah I hear you and yeah the work that I tend to do, we've got the same setup. So we have a zero childcare spend, which I know is a really nice position because I'm here. So I do it all. But yeah, after school, mummy will bring you a snack, but then you're welcome to sit on the sofa next to me as I work and do what I need to do. You know, I don't see clients at those times. So I don't see clients at those times so I don't see clients with with kids in the room or on the sofa but you know the bits like you know doing my zero um accounting stuff that takes time doesn't it and you know reconciling your invoices and checking your emails and I write quite a lot of stuff for the media and I know you do too so
所以我不会在房间里或沙发上有孩子的情况下看诊。但你知道的，像处理零税率会计之类的事情是需要时间的，对吧？核对发票、检查电子邮件，我还要为媒体写很多东西，我知道你也是，所以
you know that takes time and that tends to be the sort of things I'll be doing when the children are home yeah I mean I'm exactly the same um I had to do a an article yesterday um actually something slightly different to what I normally talk about as well which was quite nice so um so I don't don't talk about it that much on podcasts but I had postpartum psychosis when Ben was little um he was about eight weeks old he was born with um a compressed neck muscle so he cried non-stop for 10 weeks um he slept in 20 minute bursts and I was just so overwhelmed so sleep deprived and I started having hallucinations and I just went a bit crazy for a while and it was it was a very very scary situation but like that I got asked to do a um to do an article about that yesterday because it's mental health awareness month and I was writing
你知道的，那需要时间，而那往往是我在孩子们在家时会做的事情。是的，我的情况完全一样。我昨天必须写一篇文章——实际上内容和我的常规话题稍微有点不同，这挺不错的。所以，我平时在播客里不怎么谈这个，但在本（Ben）很小的时候，我曾患过产后精神病（postpartum psychosis）。他大约八周大时，出生时颈部肌肉受压，所以他连续哭闹了 10 个星期。他每次只能睡 20 分钟。我当时压力太大了，严重睡眠不足，开始出现幻觉。我有一阵子真的有点崩溃了。那是一个非常、非常可怕的情况。但就在昨天，我被邀请写一篇关于那个的文章，因为现在是心理健康意识月。我当时正在写
that and he and he like just distractions for me like especially weirdly since I've started taking my ADHD medication I can't get distracted because like I'm used to having a million trains of thought going around at all at all times and now I'm like taking my ADHD medication I've got one train of thought and if people come in from any from external I'm like it makes me really stressed and really like really uptight so like I've had to explain to my kids that mummy's brain's changing because she's, because she's got new medication and you know, the tablets I'm taking, you know, sometimes it might make me a bit snappy. And like, but they, they now know they're like, mummy, you're being snappy.
那篇文章，而他——对我来说，干扰——尤其是奇怪的是，自从我开始服用 ADHD 药物以来，我无法忍受被打扰。因为我习惯了脑子里同时转着无数个念头，而现在我吃了 ADHD 药物后，脑子里只有一个念头。如果有人从外部介入，我会感到压力极大、非常紧绷。所以，我必须向我的孩子们解释，妈妈的大脑正在改变，因为我有新药，而且我吃的药，你知道的，有时可能会让我有点急躁。但是他们现在知道了，他们会说：“妈妈，你现在很急躁，停下来。”我会被训斥，这挺好的，因为你知道的，有时我们的确需要。
Stop it. I get told off, which is good because you know, sometimes we need to. Yeah. And I think that's probably one of the things you know I think there's a number of things I want to say here like when we were talking earlier when you were talking about actually if I'd known what I'd known what I've had children and for me it's if I'd have known what I think I know would I have ended up as a psychologist or would I have thought that I was somehow broken and not worthy of that you know would I have allowed myself to do everything that I do yeah would I have thought that I was somehow broken and not worthy of that you know would I have allowed myself to do everything that I do yeah would I have felt that I was as credible
是的。而且我觉得这可能正是其中一件事——你知道，这里有很多我想说的事情。就像我们之前聊的，当你谈到“如果我早知道这些，我还会生孩子吗？”时。对我来说，如果我早知道我现在知道的这些，我还会成为一名心理学家吗？还是会认为自己有什么破碎的地方、不配拥有这一切？你知道，我还会允许自己做我所做的一切吗？是的，我会觉得自己配不上这份信赖吗？
um would I so I you know I did really pretty well at school um I think I'd have done even better if I'd had some accountability so for me the wheels fell off a bit in A-levels um because I was just chilling out and having some naps in the room. There wasn't anyone going, come on, Marianne, get that work done. Get that work done. You need to do that. And, you know, for biology, I did biology A level. All I had to do for each module was read a book that was probably A4, but was quite thin.
嗯，我，你知道的，我在学校表现得相当不错，嗯，我想如果我能有一些监督和督促，我会做得更好。所以对我来说，我的学业在A-Level（高级水平考试）时有点脱节了，因为我当时只是在房间里放松、打盹。没有什么人在旁边说，来吧，玛丽安，把那个作业完成。把那个作业完成。你需要做那个。而且，你知道的，对于生物学，我选修了生物学A-level。我每个模块只需要读一本书，可能只有A4纸大小，但相当薄。
That's all I had to do for each module. And I probably would have got an A. I didn't do it. I didn't do it. And I got a D. And I think that's a real shame because I definitely was capable of it, you know, and actually the bits that I really liked, like I really, I perhaps could even have a go now. I'm not going to, cause it'd be boring, but the nitrogen cycle involving lightning and soil and all of that, like I, I, I knew it all like,
这就是我每个模块需要做的全部事情。我本来可能会得个A。我没去做。我没去做。结果我得了个D。我觉得这真的很遗憾，因为我绝对有这个能力，你知道的，而且实际上那些我真的很喜欢的模块，比如我真的，我现在甚至可能想去尝试一下。我不会去，因为那会很无聊，但是涉及闪电、土壤以及所有这些的氮循环，就像我，我，我全都一清二楚，
you know, because I found it fascinating um but if I had been recognized and someone had said right Marianne I can see that you're struggling for this I want you to do one chapter at a time and then I want you to write me a brief summary about it that would have been the difference that made the difference for me absolutely so the wheels fell off for me at college as well and university because I didn't have like I knew that if I didn't do my work, what are they going to do about it? They're not going to give me a detention, are they? Whereas at school there was there were consequences for not doing your work. And when I like the refectory was like the place where I lived and I went to college every day, but I didn't actually go to my lectures half the time. I'd like bum around, like just socialising because it was way more fun and i realized that
你知道的，因为我觉得这很迷人，嗯，但如果当时有人认可我，对我说，对吧，玛丽安，我看出你在这门课上有点吃力，我希望你一次读一章，然后给我写一个简短的总结，那将会是那个带来改变的关键所在，绝对是这样。所以我的大学阶段也同样一团糟，因为我没有……我知道如果我不做作业，他们能把我怎么样？他们总不能关我禁闭吧？而在学校里，不做作业是有后果的。当我去餐厅时，那就像是我生活的地方，我每天都去大学，但我有一半的时间其实根本没去上讲座。我只会瞎晃悠，比如光顾着社交，因为那样有趣得多，而且我意识到
actually i did the wrong subjects so i was really good at languages and i should have done languages but instead i did english because my mom kind of made she didn't make me do it but it was like you have to do one academic subject and i did art i loved art but i was so weird as an artist that they didn't get me they just didn't understand me at all so I'm like putting down all this like weird probably futuristic like now you're thinking like you know you look at like the Tracey Emin stuff that was the kind of things that I was doing but it wasn't art because it wasn't traditional art um and I did textiles but like that wasn't really for me either I did media studies because I wanted to be
实际上我选错了科目，所以我其实很擅长语言类，我本该选语言的，但相反我选了英语，因为我妈妈有点……她倒不是逼我选，而是那种“你必须选一门学术科目”的态度。我还选了艺术，我热爱艺术，但我作为艺术生实在太怪异了，他们根本不懂我，完全不理解我。所以我画了所有这些奇怪的、大概很具未来感的东西——现在你会觉得，你知道的，你看那些特雷西·艾敏（Tracey Emin）的作品，那就是我当时在做的那种东西，但这根本不算艺术，因为它不是传统艺术，嗯，我还选了纺织品设计，但这其实也不太适合我。我选了传媒研究，因为我想成为
a radio presenter that was all I ever wanted to do and then when I went to university I joined the radio station I hyper focused on the radio station so much that I became the station manager I forgot I even did a degree um and then about four years in they were like Maddy you don't go here anymore you have to leave so I was like okay so I completely flunked out of university um ended up just getting into ridiculous amounts of debt because I got into a dopamine spending cycle um where I basically just to make myself happy I spent money on whatever I could and that was a really really bad cycle and I'm wondering if if I'd have not gone to university not been pushed down that route I'd gone and done a business apprenticeship or a marketing
一名电台主持人，那是我唯一想做的事。然后当我上了大学，我加入了广播电台，我全神贯注于广播电台，以至于我成了台长，我都忘了自己其实还在读一个学位，嗯，然后大约四年后，他们说：“麦迪，你不再是这里的学生了，你必须离开。”所以我当时就想：“好吧。”于是我彻底把大学读砸了，最后欠下了巨额债务，因为我陷入了多巴胺消费的循环中，我基本上为了让自己开心，把钱花在任何我能买的东西上，那真是一个非常非常糟糕的循环。我在想，如果我当初没有去大学，没有被推向那条路，而是去参加一个商业学徒计划或市场营销
apprenticeship something that was on the table for me would it have been different it's weird but you know I don't regret any step of my life because it's given me all of the life lessons that I've got today every single thing that I did has kind of built up to this moment. And now for the first time in my life, I actually feel like I'm successful because I know how to manage my brain, which is something that I've never known how to do before. And I always assumed that I was failing. Now I know that I'm actually rocking it for how good my brain is not not how good it is that's not me saying that like people who have got neurodivergent conditions don't have good brains but they work differently so now I know that I work differently and I run my business in a
学徒计划，某个当时摆在我面前的选择，一切会不会有所不同？这很奇怪，但你知道的，我不后悔我人生中的任何一步，因为它赋予了我今天所拥有的所有人生经验。我做过的每一件事都为这一刻奠定了基础。现在，我人生中第一次真正觉得自己成功了，因为我知道如何管理我的大脑，这是我以前从未知道该怎么做的事情。我过去总是认为自己一直在失败。现在我知道，鉴于我的大脑有多棒，我其实过得很出色——这不是说那些患有神经多样性状况的人的大脑不好，而是他们的运作方式不同。所以现在我知道我的运作方式不同，我以一种
different way it it's so game-changing I'm so pleased you've had that experience and I feel like we now need to pause for a joint sing of like this is my moment by Martine McCutcheon like I feel that you know being 42 as well I feel just strong and capable and able and I've been doing personal training for the last two and a half years and I just really like where I'm at right now. You know, the balance of the different types of work that I do, it just really suits me. Having slightly older children, age seven and ten, I think suits me as well. You know, I just, yeah, I like where I'm at right now.
不同的方式经营我的生意，这太具有变革性了。我很高兴你有过这样的经历，我觉得我们现在需要暂停一下，一起来合唱一首玛蒂恩·麦卡琴（Martine McCutcheon）的《这就是我的时刻》（This is My Moment）。我觉得，你知道的，作为一个42岁的人，我也觉得自己很强大、很有能力、能够胜任一切。在过去的两年半里，我一直在进行私人健身训练，我真的很喜欢我现在的状态。你知道的，我所做的不同类型工作的平衡，真的很适合我。拥有稍微大一点的孩子，七岁和十岁，我觉得也很适合我。你知道，我就是，是的，我喜欢我现在的状态。
And that's a really powerful thing to be able to say. And actually, you know, I'm imagining much younger Maddy, who actually was quite confused and lonely at times, you know, to be able to give her that sense that you're going to feel like this in your 40s is so powerful. I would never in a million years, if you just said to me, and weirdly, I looked at my yearbook the other day. And it's like, what do you want to be when you grow up? And I just put influential at what I do how weird is that so I was like okay so not only am I an influencer I teach people how to be the go-to expert in their niche um and I'm a you know
能够说出这样的话是一件非常有力的事情。而且实际上，你知道的，我在想象那个年轻得多的麦迪，她当时其实相当困惑，有时也很孤独，你知道的，能给她那种“你在40多岁时就会有这种感觉”的信念，是如此充满力量。如果有人对我说，我做梦也想不到——说来也奇怪，我前几天翻看了我的毕业纪念册。上面写着：“你长大后想做什么？”我当时写的是：“在我所做的事情上发挥影响力。”这有多奇怪？所以我当时就想，好吧，我不仅是一个意见领袖（influencer），我还在教人们如何成为他们所在领域的首选专家，嗯，而且我是一个，你知道的，
somebody who actually people like to listen to um but I would never in a million years if you'd have said to me that I'd be doing what I do now I always thought like working in an office job something like sales I mean sales like I have learned a lot about sales in the in the process and like the jobs I've done before but my my career was so bumpy before I decided to be self-employed I didn't fit in anywhere in the workplace um I had no friends I was bullied um I I was an oversharer I didn't fit well into an office environment I I needed to work on my own so that I could give my brain some space to actually work um but if but if you'd have said to me years ago Maddy you will be in the press every single week you'll be on national radio you'll have a book deal in the process like you know I would have
真正有人愿意倾听的人，嗯，但如果你在几年前对我说，我会每周都出现在媒体上，我会上国家广播电台，在这个过程中我还会拿到一本书的出版合同，你知道的，我当时会……
gone no way there's no way I'm gonna write a book not in the process like you know I would have gone no way there's no way I'm gonna write a book not a chance in hell but here I am writing a book so yeah I never would have thought it well I'm so pleased that you are in such a good place right now and that yeah I'm excited to see what comes next for you. Could you tell our audience a little bit about where they can find you and what you do? Yeah, absolutely. So I refer to myself as a multi-potentialite. Basically, I do all of the things. As a what now?
觉得“绝不可能”。绝对不可能，我怎么会写书？门儿都没有！但现在我就在这里写书。所以，是的，我从来没想过。好吧，我很高兴你现在处于这么好的状态，而且，是的，我很期待接下来会为你带来什么。你能跟我们的观众稍微讲讲他们可以在哪里找到你以及你是做什么的吗？好的，没问题。所以我称自己为“多重潜力者”（multi-potentialite）。基本上，我什么都做。作为一个什么？
Multi-potentialite. So I have two different businesses, but the thing that holds them all together is me. So my personal brand. So I've spent the last the last eight years being self-employed, growing a personal brand as a money specialist. I'm a bit different to everybody else because I talk about neurodiversity and money and how that shows up for different people. That's my niche. So I've grown as an expert in my niche in the money industry. But now I teach other people to do it as well. So whatever their niche is, I help them to get visible, I help them to get in the press, I help them to grow their social media and their followings. I do one to one coaching for business mentorship. So I've had a very interesting business
多重潜力者。所以我有两家不同的公司，但把它们串联在一起的是我本人。也就是我的个人品牌。因此，在过去的八年里，我一直自己创业，以资金专家的身份打造个人品牌。我和其他人有点不同，因为我谈论的是神经多样性与金钱的关系，以及这如何在不同的人身上体现出来。这就是我的细分领域。所以我在金融行业的细分领域成长为了一名专家。但现在我也在教其他人这样做。所以无论他们的细分领域是什么，我都帮助他们提高曝光率，帮助他们在媒体上亮相，帮助他们扩大社交媒体和粉丝群体。我为商业导师身份提供一对一的辅导。所以我的商业生涯
career, I have bought businesses, I've sold sold businesses but I've also had quite a fair few failed ones and those are the ones that have taught me everything that I need to know about business because they're the things that you know you don't want to make as a business owner so I now spend 50% of my time working either one-to-one with people or in my membership I've got a membership that helps neurodivergent entrepreneurs to get visible um i do um tiktok training courses once a month they're always free so if anyone wants any information come follow me and get get started on those and then my my other side is that i run an app called mad about money which is a community for neurodivergence to help them with money business well-being lifestyle and anything that relates back to their living situation
非常有趣，我买过公司，我也卖过公司，但我也经历过相当多的失败案例，而正是这些失败教给了我关于商业所需了解的一切，因为这些都是你作为企业主不想犯的错误。所以我现在把50%的时间花在与人们进行一对一的辅导上，或者投入到我的会员社群中。我有一个会员社群，帮助神经多样性创业者提高曝光率，嗯，我每个月都会举办一次TikTok培训课程，这些课程总是免费的，所以如果任何人想要任何信息，快来关注我并开始学习吧。然后我的另一个业务是我运营着一个名为“疯狂谈钱”（Mad About Money）的应用程序，这是一个针对神经多样性人群的社群，旨在帮助他们解决金钱、商业、健康、生活方式以及任何与其生活状况相关的问题。
mad about money makes a lot more sense to me the name now actually I just that that passed me by but it's that double entendre isn't it yeah it is it is um and I didn't want to call it like anything that I wanted a bit of a touch of me but I didn't want to call it like anything that i wanted a bit of a touch of me but i didn't want to be the brand because i've made that mistake in the past where i've run a business and the brand has been all consuming and it's all been me but it's now it's one of my products that i that i have um it's a free to download app so if anyone's struggling with with neurodiversity or um money problems that it's an open inclusive lovely place to hang out because there's no judgment ever um it's all full of neurodivergence and people who understand
现在听来，“疯狂谈钱”这个名字对我来说更有意义了。其实之前这个双关语我都没注意到。对，确实是的，嗯，我不想把它命名为……我希望里面有一点我自己的印记，但我不想把它命名为……我希望里面有一点我自己的印记，但我不希望自己成为这个品牌本身，因为我过去犯过这样的错误，我曾经营过一家公司，而那个品牌占据了全部，全都是我。但现在它只是我拥有的产品之一，嗯，这是一个免费下载的应用程序，所以如果任何人正在与神经多样性或金钱问题作斗争，这是一个开放、包容、可爱的地方，大家可以在这里交流，因为这里永远没有评判，这里全都是神经多样性人群以及能够理解
each other which is nice um but yeah that's that's kind of where where i where i grow and i started my tiktok channel mad about money official um about a year and a half ago and I show up every day I give tips on money I give tips on business I give tips on TikTok and the good thing about that is normally you'd be like but all of those things are all like really different things but I pull them together with my personality to make a personal brand and it just seems to work so amazing I'm pretty rubbish at TikTok so I'll make sure I come on one of my training courses I will I will um and I guess what I don't want our audience to to think as a as a finishing note really is that if they are recognizing that they might have some neurodiversity that they're not employable because actually that's not at all
彼此的人，这感觉很好。嗯，但这就是我成长的地方。大约一年半前，我开通了我的TikTok频道“Mad About Money Official”，我每天都出镜，分享关于金钱的技巧，关于商业的技巧，关于TikTok的技巧。好处在于，通常你可能会觉得：“等一下，所有这些事情看起来都完全不同啊。”但我用我的个人品牌将它们通过我的个性串联在了一起，而且它似乎真的很奏效！太棒了，我在TikTok上其实挺菜的，所以我一定要去参加你的其中一期培训课程，我一定会去的，嗯。而且我想，作为最后的总结，我真的不希望我们的观众认为，如果他们意识到自己可能存在某种神经多样性，就觉得他们无法被雇佣，因为实际上情况根本不是这样的，
what we're saying and actually what my experience of moving from job to job is that some people will be your tribe and will adore you and worship you and others may not get you and that's okay to just move on and move on to the next and wait for your tribe yeah so let me let me let me go into a little bit more detail about that i know it was short on time, but with my situation, it was always I didn't have the right support in the workplace. So there is a free grant called Access to Work, which helps to support people who are neurodivergent in the workplace to help them to stay in the workplace. Also as well, I do neurodiversity in the workplace training for managers who have neurodivergent staff or people who suspect that they're neurodivergent because it's about utilising the correct skills for the correct roles and supporting people with neurodivergent conditions so that they can actually enjoy being in the workplace. Nowadays, like I mean we're
这并不是我们要表达的。实际上，我从一份工作跳槽到另一份工作的经验是，有些人会成为你的同道中人并对你爱慕有加、视若珍宝，而另一些人可能无法理解你，这也没关系，大可以继续前行，寻找下一个地方，等待你的同道中人出现。是的，所以让我，让我，让我再详细讲讲这一点。我知道时间有限，但在我的情况下，总是因为我在职场中没有获得正确支持。所以有一笔名为“工作通行证”（Access to Work）的免费资助，它旨在帮助支持职场中的神经多样性人群，帮助他们留在职场中。此外，我还为那些管理着神经多样性员工、或是怀疑员工具有神经多样性的管理者提供“职场神经多样性”培训，因为这关乎为正确的岗位利用正确的技能，并支持患有神经多样性状况的人，让他们能够真正享受在职场中的时光。如今，我的意思是，我们
talking 10 years ago that I was employed um back then there was no knowledge of neurodiversity in any way shape or form so I wasn't accepted in the workplace nowadays completely different story yeah there's been such a flexibility you know curve hasn't that really and yeah everything is about inclusivity now and you know I think it's long overdue you know and if we'd's long overdue, you know. And if we'd been even having to try to have these conversations 10 years ago, probably nobody would have listened. It would have been, oh, it's a fad.
谈论的是我10年前受雇的时候，在那时，对于神经多样性根本没有任何形式的认知，所以我当时在职场中并未被接纳。而现在完全是另一回事了。是的，如今有了如此大的灵活性，是不是真的？而且，是的，现在一切都关乎包容性，你知道的，而且我认为这早就该实现了，你知道的，如果我们甚至不得不试着在10年前就进行这些对话，可能根本没有人会听。当时人们只会觉得：“哦，这只是一阵风潮。
It's like, it's silly. Like, it's just, you know. Same as mental health. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Thank you so much for your time. I hope that the rest of your journey with your early days of med continues to go well. I love the way I think part of me would be like a bit worried about what if my brain wasn't like like this like how have you got around that before we finish it's really interesting how much it changed and
这就像是，太傻了。这只是，你知道的。”就像对待心理健康一样。对，对，对，对。非常感谢你抽出时间。希望你关于梅德（Med）初期的整段旅程能继续顺利。我喜欢这种感觉……我想我的一部分人会有点担心，如果我的大脑不像这样会怎么样？在我结束之前，你是如何克服这一点的？这真的很奇妙，它的改变有多大，尤其是
especially as it has unmasked the the autism side um and it's also I think made my dyspraxia worse as well like I mean I've got a nickname with my group of friends Spilly Maddy because it's like who how many seconds can I be at a party before I spill something or trip over or knock over a table um it's made me so much worse but also like I think one of the things that I struggle with is people and soaking up people's energies because I'm a bit of an empath um so I've had to really really learn how to be around people again which is strange for me because I'm quite a sociable person from an ADHD perspective um my focus is so much better. My organisation is so much better.
当它揭开了自闭症这一面的面纱时，而且我也认为它让我的发育协调障碍（dyspraxia）变得更严重了，比如说，我和我的朋友们之间有一个绰号叫“冒失鬼麦迪”（Spilly Maddy），因为就像是：我能在派对上待几秒钟不把东西洒了、不被绊倒或不把桌子撞翻？它让我变得严重得多。但同时，我认为我一直在挣扎的一点是人际关系以及吸收别人的能量，因为我有点共情能力过强（empath），所以我不得不真正地、真正地重新学习如何与人相处，这对我来说很奇怪，因为从多动症（ADHD）的角度来看，我其实是一个挺善于社交的人。我的注意力好多了。我的组织能力好多了。
But I don't take my meds at the weekends because I still need some time for my brain to be creative because otherwise I feel like it's turned everything off. Like the first week of taking my meds, I was sat in the car and I turned the radio off and I couldn't hear anything. And it was the weirdest, weirdest thing in the world. I turned the radio off and I couldn't hear anything and it was the weirdest weirdest thing in the world it was like silence and I've never had that in my entire life I have always got an inner monologue I've always got constant talking my inner monologues disappeared which is a really really weird adjustment and it's been weighing up the pros and cons of whether or not I actually like that or whether I don't like that um so I've kind of agreed with my doctors I take it in the morning
但我周末不吃药，因为我仍然需要一些时间让我的大脑发挥创造力，否则我觉得药物把一切都关闭了。就像我吃药的第一周，我坐在车里，把收音机关了，结果我什么也听不见。那绝对是世界上最奇怪、最诡异的事情。我把收音机关了，却什么也听不见，那绝对是世界上最奇怪、最诡异的事情。那感觉就像是一片死寂，我这辈子从来没有经历过这种情况。我的脑海里总是有一个内在的独白，总是有喋喋不休的声音，而我的内在独白消失了，这是一个非常非常奇怪的适应过程，我一直在权衡利弊，看我究竟是喜欢这样还是不喜欢这样。所以我算是跟医生达成了一致：我早上吃药，
so I can get my focus in I can do my work but then I don't take my second dose which a lot of people do um so that I can get my creativity and my brain can start working um it also it helps me a lot with anxiety as well so I will carry on taking them but I'm also being really really hyper aware that it is changing me a little bit and I've said to all of my friends if it changes me to the point where I'm not maddy anymore you need to let me know and I'll come off them because I'm maddy I I am unstoppable, unique, inspiring, fun, energetic, all of these things. And if any of those things go away, then I need to not be on them. Thank you for sharing. You know, what we know is that there is a high percentage of people with neurodiversity in caring professions. So I think this will be really interesting listening for so many,
这样我可以集中注意力，完成工作，但我接着不吃第二剂药——很多人都会吃第二剂——这样我就可以保持创造力，我的大脑就可以开始运转。它对我的焦虑也有很大帮助，所以我将继续吃药，但我也保持着非常非常高度的警惕，意识到它确实在一定程度上改变了我。我已经对所有的朋友说过了，如果它把我改变得不再是麦迪了，你们一定要告诉我，我会停药的，因为我就是麦迪，我是势不可挡的、独一无二的、鼓舞人心的、有趣的、充满活力的，所有这些特质都在。如果其中任何一个特质消失了，那我就不需要再吃药了。谢谢你的分享。你知道的，我们所知道的是，在护理行业中，患有神经多样性的人比例很高。所以我想这对于许许多多、
so many people. So thank you for spending your time with us so warmly. Please do come and follow Maddy. We will make sure that the links are on screen and in the show notes as well. Thank you again, Maddy. Thanks for having me. Thank you so much to our guest, Maddy. What an incredibly honest, thought-provoking, inspiring, compassionate discussion that was. I would love to know what your thoughts on this are. Would you like to see more conversations from people that have been diagnosed or had certain experiences of certain conditions? Do let me know. And yeah, has this evoked anything for you, for your own thinking, for your own experiences or for those around you? If you found this helpful, please do rate and review us on the podcast platform you're listening to. Or if you're on YouTube, please do
许许多多的人来说会是一场非常有趣的访谈。非常感谢你如此热情地与我们共度这段时间。请大家一定要来关注麦迪。我们一定会把链接放在屏幕上以及节目简介里。再次谢谢你，麦迪。谢谢邀请我。非常感谢我们的嘉宾麦迪。那是一场令人难以置信的坦诚、引人深思、备受鼓舞且充满同理心的讨论。我很想知道你对此有什么看法。你是否希望看到更多关于那些被诊断出患有某种病症或对某些病症有特定经历的人的对话？请务必告诉我。还有，是的，这是否唤起了你关于自己的思考、你自身的经历或你周围人的经历的任何共鸣？如果你觉得这有帮助，请务必在你正在收听的播客平台上给我们打分和评论。如果你在YouTube上，请务必
like and subscribe, drop me a comment. And one of the most helpful things you can do for the podcast, which will take you just one moment, is if you are listening on Spotify, if you are listening on Apple Podcasts, it's just to follow the show. It helps us immeasurably Trent everywhere. And you can also nip on in to the Aspiring Psychologist community free Facebook group. Come and discuss this episode there. Let me know what you think. And don't forget, we've got the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can access from just £30 a month, and it will help you to supercharge your chances of shooting for your psychology dreams. And we've also got the Clinical Psychologist Collective and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, which get wonderful reviews too. If you would like your voice at the start and the end of any of these podcasts then do let me know and we can
点赞、订阅并给我留言。你可以为播客做的最有帮助的事情之一，而且只需花你的一小会儿时间，就是如果你在Spotify上收听，如果你在Apple Podcasts上收听，只需点击关注节目。这能给我们带来不可估量的帮助。你也可以顺便加入“有抱负的心理学家社群”免费Facebook群组。来那里讨论这一集吧。让我知道你的想法。别忘了，我们还有“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”，你只需每月30英镑即可加入，它将助你极大地提升实现心理学梦想的机会。我们还有“临床心理学家集体”（Clinical Psychologist Collective）和“有抱负的心理学家集体”（Aspiring Psychologist Collective），它们也获得了极佳的评价。如果你希望在这些播客的开头和结尾听到你的声音，请务必告诉我，我们可以
help sort out an audio testimonial and that would be so appreciated thank you for being part of my world thank you for trusting me to help you in your journey in mental health and stay kind to yourselves and i will see you for our next episode which will be available from 10 a.m. on Saturdays on YouTube and from 6 a.m. as an MP3 on Mondays. Take care. Be kind. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical
帮你安排一个音频感谢寄语，我们会非常感激。感谢你成为我世界的一部分，感谢你信任我，让我陪伴你走过心理健康之旅。大家要善待自己，我们将在下一期节目中见面，节目将于周六上午10点在YouTube上发布，周一上午6点作为MP3音频发布。保重。善待他人。如果你想成为一名心理学家，就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将迈向获得资格的道路。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）主持的《有抱负的心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我叫亚娜（Jana），我是一名实习心理健康从业人员。我读了《临床
Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
心理学家集体》这本书。我发现里面关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。它让我惊叹于通往那里的途径竟然有那么多，而且并没有哪一种是成为心理学家的完美方式。这在某种程度上让我充满了信心，让我知道“不，我并没有做错”，并减轻了我自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，你就绝对不会把它放下。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。